[Music]
in the internet never forgets news
that's what's that submitted by yang-gon
20 22 0 to Z Yangon Yangon comedian
Shane Gillis was fired from SNL days
after a racially charged podcast was
spread around online yes this was pretty
stupid podcast was in 20 September of
2018 it was reset now pretty recent I
don't even know what the bit was the
whole thing because people were like oh
you got to listen to the whole thing to
understand it no there's no bit though
yeah he's just doing that well people
okay yeah cuz I don't know what's going
on I saw parts of it but new new cast
member of SNL so he won't want to do for
myself I want you guys to do for me I
think for you want to feed my thoughts
no no no I'm good too
so he was announced as a new SNL cast
member as well as two other people that
have are now new cast members and one of
them name is Bowen yang who is the very
first full Asian to be a cast member
what cuz they were part Asian um Fred
Armisen order yes partition tiny full
Asian cast member so it was a big deal
until wait is any gay - so it's like
Asian and gay
I might be mistaken but yeah I'm not
sure but he's gay is he foliation there
I don't think so now his parents
probably don't accept him I'm double
checking for the other people because I
might I might have got a mixed up with
another guy but yeah so moving on so
initially it was huge news that Bowen
got casters like what that's awesome yay
but then that was quickly overshadowed
by
completely overshadowed I would say
immediately yeah like to the point where
no one even knows he's gonna be a cast
member of SNL yeah until he shows up but
they're gonna be like oh this guy
because he was what overshadowed him was
these these racist remarks by Shane
Gillis which is the New Testament cast
membered honest Annelle right she's my
Robin it was tweeted out that said today
SNL announced the hiring of its first
cast member of East Asian descent and
also this guy with two clips and I have
a video of both clips kind of merged
into like a minute and 18 seconds for
you guys you guys can see some of the
stuff you think thank you it's pretty
good it is full [ __ ] China yeah I
wonder how that started they just built
one [ __ ] up looking building and
people were like all right no one said
anything about chinks live there we got
in there and we sat down and baby girl
was like I'm so excited for neuters then
I was like yo chill chill chill she's
like I'm so sorry
she said New Jersey yeah [ __ ] yeah and
it's it's full [ __ ] shiny in there
isn't that kind of like nice though
isn't that being when when people go
into a Mexican restaurant like altitude
tacos
oh god I love all of spicy neuters but
we had in the translation between you
and the waiter yeah it's just such a
[ __ ] hassle it's like can you I'm
pointing at this is the bucket
well actually I put numbers like 57 yeah
this one even with the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
I was like that sauce again that one's
yeah my medium or
yeah like medium no medium nice do you
think Asian guys are trying to learn
English bothers me more than someone
listens like lil uzi Curt welcome trendy
[ __ ] dinner that's hilarious
that wasn't accurate ah spicy oh
whatever
did he direct anything towards the other
guy bone yang no so this is from
September 2018 yeah so people are like
how could you hire this guy who is so
very clearly racist towards Asians along
with an Asian guys what like it's just
like he supports Chinese businesses he
buys a lot of neuters what words kind of
[ __ ] up is the chinks said in this
because he was emphasizing I mean so the
thing is um what happened after was he
was like yeah man as a comedian you know
sometimes I really yeah so so what
exactly so what made it worse was his
was his excuse this is what it what he
wrote I'm glad he's done this is what he
wrote on Twitter would you like to read
it Steve yes I was spicy I'm a comedian
who pushes boundaries I sometimes miss
if you go through my 10 years of comedy
most of it bad you're going to find a
lot of bad misses I'm happy to apologize
to anyone who's actually offended by
anything I've said my intention is never
to hurt anyone I'm trying to be the best
comedian I could be and sometimes that
requires risks so the thing is I don't
really think that the other things that
you said was the the triggering point
it's his usage of the word [ __ ] I agree
yeah he doesn't even think that's a
racist word so that's how stupid he is
yeah he's like I'm just pushing
boundaries yeah well by that logic if
you're really pushing boundaries you
should use the n-word yeah because that
would be the ultimate man wearing
blackface
yeah and wear a tuxedo that's his comedy
but I mean the fact that he doesn't even
address that he use that word it's like
that's kind of weird that's the only
thing to me because I'm like the rest of
it I could see where maybe you're trying
to construct some kind of bit out of
this thing I mean we did the best ones
out of Chinese way like it's it's like
there's a lot of good jokes to be had
out of like that situation is
those are what he presented you just
sort of was like going with the
observational kind of thing but it's
like at that point just like oh so
you're just like commenting on how like
annoyed you are that this person is
trying to learn English this is not just
it's not funny yeah I mean I've heard
I've heard David say all of that but you
know what he does it in a way that's
funny right so that but that's what I'm
saying so I understand the intention
behind it but the sure there wasn't a
bit but the chinks word was lame yeah it
wasn't it wasn't funny it was just
shitty yeah he's also so they're also
saying which I don't have excerpts of
exactly what he said but they're saying
that he has said sexist and homophobic
comments as well so it's like a lot of
things that were just really offensive
that it just seems like a stupid [ __ ] to
me yeah we're just I mean to me it's
which is fine and comedy you can you
know push the boundary there's a ton of
stupid fun but if you're just kind of if
you're just using racial slurs as a way
to just push the boundaries and be
shocking to me that's not comedy its
lordship yeah it's there's nothing
constructed about no yeah he also called
Andrew yang deaf some say this isn't
funny [ __ ] man this is not funny like
I'm laughing at the fact of how how
stupid that is I can't wait to defend
comedians you guys know this but this is
not comedy right it's crazy that he made
it on the cast of SNL right because I
heard the auditioning process it's like
really late well maybe he's good I'm
sure he was good man I had no doubt I'm
sure he's just not a comedian
it's just that whatever this was was not
his thing yeah yes like freeform [ __ ]
flow of the mind thought that's our
thing right they said in a statement on
behalf of producer Lorne Michaels they
said after talking with Shane Gillis we
have decided that he will not be joining
SNL we want SNL to have a variety of
voices and points of view within the
show the language he used is offensive
hurtful and unacceptable we are sorry
that we did not see these clips earlier
that and that our vetting process was
not up to our standards so then that's
when Shane came out with this statement
this book keeps [ __ ] up dude
would you like to read
he's like I can't believe all these
changes who would that be nuts yeah
hilarious down on it if you got my back
yeah it feels ridiculous for comedians
to be making serious public statements
but here we are I'm a comedian who was
funny enough to get SNL that can't be
taken away it was of course I wanted an
opportunity to prove myself
at SNL but I understand it would be too
much of a distraction I respect the
decision they made I'm honestly grateful
for the opportunity I was always a mad
TV guy anyway that's kind of funny bro
you know that's your shot yeah I'd be
salty it's a career starter or Stoppard
if I was mad TV or other producers I'm
like this fools gonna be a handful for
me I'm not gonna [ __ ] hire a salty
ass listen I would hate ages for every
system further into the corner of every
super races but now he has a reason you
know it'll make them think it'll make
these people think twice that's right so
this guy has no ties to Boeing it's just
the fact that he was in oh okay
yeah because I thought they had beef for
some reason that would be funny I think
people are just commenting on how
tone-deaf it is if you like knew all
this stuff beforehand but you're also
like trying to champion this is like oh
look at how inclusive we are all sorry
Ari like you're Brandi's not as if I see
its weak to hide behind the whole like
this is where comedians are right now
when your bit is just saying the n-word
or whatever so uh Andrew yang responded
to his first thing about pushing
boundaries of stuff he said Shane I
prefer comedy that makes people think
and doesn't take cheap shots but I'm
happy to sit down and talk with you if
you like for the record I do not think
you should lose his job we would you
would benefit from being more forgiving
rather than punitive we are all humans
my take on it so the thing if he came
out if he came out and he was like hey I
didn't know cheek was actually a bad
word I grew up in a [ __ ] bubble and
you know I was just the way I grew up
and I'm like cool now you know yeah you
won't use it again but the fact that
he's like defending the youth right like
oh I'm just doing [ __ ] bits it's like
come on man
that doesn't make sense because you
would never use the n-word this guy
never would he never yeah see that's
what I wish he did instead of doing that
what he did he came out and said I fight
down what a stupid bit you know I mean
like what a dumb idea of a bit right
yeah but instead of this like I'm hiding
behind like comedians are under fire
right now and I'll [ __ ] it's like you're
not part of that bro that I'm a bad tip
you got anyway it's like you keep hiding
because a ton of comics that were like
dude where was the bit right then I
don't see it so how is that defending if
there was a bit then it's like okay I
see how he's defending comedy like Dave
Chappelle right I didn't get what he did
but in this case it's just I'm just
gonna talk some [ __ ] yeah it was nothing
so and reading tweeted out that he and
Shane will sit down Wow he's gonna meet
with the president of Asians that's
pretty good that's pretty dope who else
right now is the president of Asians I
have it's [ __ ] Andrew yang I thought
we were I mean no offense bro but you
know I mean just a lot more exposure
there that's true yeah I'd like to but I
don't think people would want me dude
can you imagine Joe on CNN I [ __ ] dad
murder it yeah really yeah I do I'd be
something that you'd be on for three
minutes and then you're like hold on a
second I was just talking about turtles
[Music]
[Music]